bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat de reportage et
d'expertise sur Public Sénat vous le
savez la promesse elle est dans le titre
de cette émission donnée du sens à
l'actualité et vous proposer chaque jour
des clés de compréhension des mutations
de notre société 90 minutes et deux
débats l'actualité pour commencer et la
France qui a finalement décidé
d'accueillir l'océan Viking et ses 234
migrants rescapés de leur traversée de
la Méditerranée
la situation humanitaire à bord du
navire Ocean Viking appelle une action
désormais immédiate chaque heure
supplémentaire de navigation fait
désormais courir des risques très
importants pour la vie de certains de
ces passagers c'est la fin d'un bras de
fer entre la France et l'Italie et le
début d'une crise diplomatique qui
pourrait durer la nouvelle Première
ministre italienne Georgia Meloni lance
un défi à la France et à l'Europe
pendant des bas dans une minute et puis
vous le savez dans cette émission on
choisit chaque jour un thème
volontairement décalé de l'actualité
après la mort de la jeune Lola nous
avons décidé d'attendre plusieurs
semaines pour tenter de comprendre
comment les faits divers dictent si
souvent le calendrier politique avec nos
invités chercheuses journalistes
magistrats on se demandera pourquoi les
faits divers nous fascine et comment les
politiques les instrumentalise mais
d'abord ces hommes ces femmes ses
enfants qui rêvent d'une vie meilleure
et qui risque la mort pour cette
Eldorado illusoire requie à bord de
l'océan vikingsteront le port de Toulon
demain le récit de cette journée avec
Audrey buttaz
hypother atterrit à l'aéroport de Bastia
à son bord 4 personnes évacuées de l'eau
jeune Viking pour raison sanitaires
demain les 230 autres passagers
débarqueront aussi sur le sol français
parmi eux 57 enfants les autorités
françaises ont pris la décision à titre
exceptionnel de pallier au comportement
inacceptable du gouvernement italien et
d'inviter le navire à rejoindre le port
militaire de Toulon il devrait y arriver
ce vendredi 11 novembre en début de
matinée il y a donc d'abord à devoir
d'humanité et nous regrettons que
l'Italie n'est pas été au rendez-vous de
ce devoir d'humanité la fin d'un bras de
fer entre la France et l'Italie il y a
plus de 20 jours lotion Viking bateau de
l'ONG SOS Méditerranée sauvant mère 234
migrants dont l'embarcation s'est échoué
il demande à l'Italie pays le plus
proche du sauvetage d'acosté en urgence
le nouveau gouvernement d'extrême droite
refuse à 43 reprises les autorités
françaises s'indignent et la tension
monte encore d'un cran quand un journal
italien annonce que la France va
accueillir le bateau à cette date
pourtant rien n'est décidé cela
ressemble à un coup de bluff de Georgia
mélony qui se fendent un communiqué nous
voulons dire à quel point nous
apprécions la décision de la France de
prendre sa part de responsabilité face à
l'urgence migratoire en ouvrant ses
ports au navire au chien de vikings mais
pendant ce temps la situation sanitaire
à bord se dégrade la France accepte donc
finalement d'accueillir l'eau chaînes
Viking mais elle prévient dès à présent
des contrôles aux frontières seront
renforcés avec son voisin transalpin
elle se dit même prête à revoir ses
liens diplomatiques avec l'Italie
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce premier débat de sciences
publiques Pascal Perino bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes politologue
professeur à Sciences Po Paris Paul
Olivier bonsoir et bienvenue
correspondante journal italien à La
Stampa et de l'agence
et Laetitia cru palitorialiste politique
qui est également à nos côtés on a
tendance une petite minute enfin on
l'espère le géographe et démographe
Gérard François Dumont
Pascal Perrine je commence avec vous
donc ce bateau Ocean Viking ou Viking je
pense que la bonne prononciation la
vérité est vérifiée juste avant en
anglais c'est Ocean Viking il sera
accueilli ce vendredi à Toulon le
gouvernement français pouvait-il faire
autrement finalement
non c'était difficile c'était difficile
on l'avait vu d'ailleurs il y a quelques
années avec la question de l'Aquarius
ou là voilà la France avait dit on
l'accueille en fait l'Espagne nous avait
pris de vitesse et l'Espagne avait
accueilli à Valence l'Aquarius là il
était il était difficile de tenir sur
une position
dans la mesure où sur lotion Viking ça
tournait ça tournait mal on l'a vu
sanitairement quatre personnes ont été
débarquées pour aller à l'hôpital de
Bastia il commençait y avoir de des
problèmes de santé parmi les 230 et
quelques migrants qui restent et là
comme l'a dit le ministre de l'Intérieur
il y a un devoir d'humanité il y a un
devoir d'humanité certes l'Italie Malte
n'ont pas respecté à la fois le droit de
la mer le droit international c'est vrai
que d'une certaine manière ils sont en
violation des règles la France ne
pouvait pas rentrer puisque au fond on
l'a vu vous savez que au-delà des eaux
territoriales il y a des zones qu'on
appelle SAR sevenus dans lequel chaque
état a des responsabilités on expliquera
en détail tout à l'heure sauver et
secourir les migrants en difficulté
Malte ne l'a pas fait l'Italie ne l'a
pas fait
la France ne pouvait pas se mettre au
niveau de l'attitude c'est vrai un peu
un qualifiable de l'Italie et de Malte
et au fond répondent aux devoir
d'humanité en faisant ce qu'il doit
faire c'est-à-dire accueillir et ce
débat il est intéressant parce qu'il a
des et finalement cette décision elle a
des conséquences de politique intérieure
on en parlera et évidemment on va
beaucoup plus en parler dans ce débat
sur le la cohésion européenne Paolo Levy
la nouvelle Première ministre italienne
Georgia Meloni elle est là où on
l'attend enfin pas de surprise d'une
certaine façon mais écoutez c'est
c'est un petit peu d'une certaine façon
non d'un côté ces dernières semaines du
jameloni avait été très rassurante avec
ses partenaires européens je vous
rappelle que elle a rencontré comme
premier leader international Emmanuel
Macron à Rome un peu en catimini
mais quand même symboliquement c'était
important parce que avant ça l'hypothèse
les Polonais donc ça ça avait été un
signe assez rassurant ensuite son
premier sa première déplacement à
l'étranger a été à Bruxelles ou elle
s'est montré très très rassurante avec
les institutions rebelles sur les
fondamentaux c'est-à-dire sur la
dénonciation de la guerre en Ukraine sur
le soutien ensemble sur le respect des
clous budgétaires européens sur
l’ancrage de l'Italie à l'Union
européenne donc en Italie il y en a
beaucoup qui ont créé mais là elle est
où la discontinuité avec Dragui on a
l'impression d'avoir et donc il fallait
avec une perruque blanc et donc il
fallait bien qu'elle marque son palais
vivre quelque chose pour son électorat
le drame c'est que c'est toujours les
plus faibles à payer le prix de tout
cela et on l'a vu avec cet épisode
affligeant de la chaîne Viking et elle
cette dame la première ministre qui se
dit patriote qui est arrivé disons au
sommet de l'Italie en revendiquant
l'amour pour l'Italie aujourd'hui je
pense qu'elle ne rend pas service à
l'Italie parce que cet épisode là il va
avoir des conséquences très très
mauvaises pour notre pays pour la
religion européenne on y reviendra
évidemment on a du temps comme toujours
dans nos débats dans ce sens public et
on détaillera les conséquences
européennes de cette décision de
l'Italie j'ai un François Dumont bonsoir
bienvenue heureux de vous accueillir
vous êtes donc géographe et démographes
professeur Université Paris Sorbonne et
directeur de la revue Population et
Avenir des bras de fer quand on a depuis
quoi de trois semaines presque
maintenant voilà ce nouveau bras de fer
démarré l'histoire se répète enfin c'est
pas malheureusement ce n'est pas très
nouveau il y a aucun doute l'histoire se
répète et ce qui est presque amusant
c'est pratiquement tous les cas tous
cinq ans depuis une vingtaine d'années
qu'on voit exactement le même phénomène
et qui en fait un imbroglio un imbroglio
qui part d'abord d'un phénomène il faut
le rappeler de volonté d'immigration
c'est-à-dire de personnes qui veulent
éviter leur pays parce qu'elles n'ont
plus d'espoir dans leur pays est-ce
qu'on le chiffre ça c'est le pourcentage
des populations est-ce que c'est
possible
des gens qui votent avec leurs pieds
c'est-à-dire qui considèrent que la
gouvernance de leur pays n'est pas bonne
et malheureusement ils n'ont pas
d'espoir dans l'amélioration de cette
gouvernance donc il décide d'essayer de
trouver champsailleurs et donc nous
avons une difficulté politique qui avec
des dommages économiques et à ce
moment-là il se tournent vers des
personnes qui sont capables d'organiser
leur transit vers des pays où il
considère que l'herbe est meilleur et
automatiquement il y a forcément des
réseaux de passeurs et des réseaux
mafieux qui effectivement se proposent
pour organiser ceci et c'est d'autant
plus facile que la Libye est un pays
complètement déstabilisé où il n'y a
plus d'État plus de plus d'autorité et
par contre il y a des personnes qui sont
prêts à participer au trafic mafieux y
compris dans les responsable soi-disant
politique reconnu internationalement
donc vous êtes tournante en fait c'est
sûr que c'est la plaque tournante en
l'espèce alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
aussi quelques flux qui partent de
Tunisie parce que la Tunisie est très
secoué par le drame libyen mais en ce
moment c'est la plate tournante et
surtout parce que vous savez dans toutes
les routes migratoires qui viennent vers
l'Europe il y en a il y en a huit à peu
près hein en réalité selon les périodes
il y a les passeurs choisissent la route
qui paraît la plus facile et la plus
rentable pour eux donc vous savez qu'il
y a une époque il y a eu les Canaries il
y a une autre époque il y a eu la Grèce
une époque qui a eu evraud en grec à
d'autres moments il y a même eu des
passages par le nord de la Russie vers
la Norvège enfin on a tout vu en la
matière et et les passeurs s'adaptent en
permanence oui bien sûr il y a eu aussi
les trois Gibraltar que j'ai oublié de
citer n'oublions jamais c'est très
important que que vous ayez commencé par
ça c'est un business c'est un trafic
c'est de voilà c'est une mafia qui vit
sur le malheur de ces de ces femmes de
ces hommes de ses enfants il y avait une
cinquantaine d'enfants et notamment des
mineurs isolés sur ce sur ce bateau
Pascal Perino il y avait aussi
une question de cohérence d'une certaine
façon pour le gouvernement français je
prolonge votre première intervention
parce que il y a quelques jours et on en
avait débattu ici même on avait deux
ministres le ministre de l'Intérieur le
ministre du Travail qui annonçait une
politique migratoire bon le texte n'est
pas encore présenté au Parlement mais
qui marchait sur deux jambes quoi avec
je vais pas reprendre la formule de
gendarme madame méchant avec les
méchants gentils avec les gentils mais
et notamment l'ouverture
de visa pour les métiers en tension donc
il y a quand même une logique un peu de
cohérence à avoir et on la retrouve
peut-être j'attends votre avis dans la
décision annoncée par Gérald Darmanin
oui je crois qu'il y a une cohérence on
peut avoir une politique j'allais dire
rigoureuse en matière de migration c'est
ce que le gouvernement apparemment
s'efforce de mettre en place et il y a
un deuxième blanc un deuxième volet à
cette affaire qui est tout simplement ce
que le ministre la terre a appelé le
devoir d'humanité c'est à dire une
puissance comme la France en effet ne
peut pas rester
indifférente devant ce bateau qui depuis
maintenant de nombreuses semaines est en
train d'aérer
et c'est inévitable d'une certaine
manière si la France croit au principe
qu'il a fonde et au principe qui font de
l'Union européenne que l'on arrive à
cette décision
d'accueillir ces 230 et quelques
migrants à Toulon demain et pourtant
quand on regarde des sondages moi ça m'a
vraiment surprise l'opinion publique
française alors je ne sais pas comment
c'est en Italie et plutôt favorable
renvoi des migrants c'est notamment là
dessus que que
on va dire grandissent ou les partis
politiques de droite ou de droite
extrême et de des coalitions se sont
formés qui a eu tant de victoire de ce
courant politique dans plusieurs pays
d'Europe mais ça on y un petit peu plus
tard Laetitia c'est effectivement un des
éléments intéressants je reste sur le la
politique française et le fait de
d'ouvrir finalement le territoire
français a des immigrants choisi parce
que c'est ça la logique
je crois Gérard François Dumont que
pendant la crise covid et vous l'avez
appris récemment il y a eu un phénomène
intéressant à nous raconter en fait le
drame aujourd'hui c'est que ces pays du
Sud perdent leurs ressources humaines
les plus dynamiques et en particulier
c'est le cas de la Tunisie je reviens
d'une conférence en Tunisie et vraiment
le problème numéro 1 c'est que les gens
les plus qualifiés quittent la Tunisie
et ils quitte la Tunisie pas seulement
parce que la Tunisie les rejettes mais
aussi parce que nous on a nous avons
tendance à les attirer parce que ces
personnes correspondent à nos besoins
c'est le cas des médecins
donc dès qu'il y a eu la crise covid du
jour au lendemain la France a été livré
800 passeports à des médecins tunisiens
comme si vous voyez la Tunisie n'avait
pas besoin de ses propres médecins et en
Tunisie quand vous allez dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs et bien les Tunisiens qui
sont dans ces écoles ont souvent déjà un
contrat avec une entreprise française
quand ils auront fini leurs études alors
que c'est bien sûr la Tunisie qui a
financé toute leur éducation et leur
formation c'est alors demande c'est oui
c'est alors demande bien sûr mais ce qui
fait si vous voulez que certains
tunisiens considèrent que la priorité du
gouvernement tunisien ce serait de
mettre en place une politique qui
empêche le départ des gens les plus
qualifiés alors effectivement je me
tourne et j'accueille dans ce débat
François Germaine qui est spécialiste de
la gouvernance du climat et des
migrations directeurs de l'Observatoire
Hugo à l'Université de Liège enseignant
à Sciences Po et à la Sorbonne et qui
publie bonsoir à vous l'écologie n'est
pas un consensus livre qui vient de
sortir aux éditions Fayard Françoise Le
Maine on commence là dans ce débat parce
que c'est le tout début du débat
à poser un peu tous les enjeux que cette
crise de l'océan Viking déclenche en
France et en Europe notamment voilà
cette décision de Georgia Meloni
première ministre italienne est-ce
qu'elle peut tenir ce blocus est-ce
qu'il y a pas une part d'hypocrisie
l'économie italienne j'imagine qu'elle a
elle aussi besoin de ses mirants
bien sûr il y a une énorme part
d'hypocrisie mais c'est une leader
nationaliste et extrémiste qui a été élu
notamment sur la promesse de faire ce
blocus et sur la promesse de ne pas
ouvrir les ports et donc très clairement
politiquement elle ne peut pas l'ouvrir
la réalité c'est que tout le débat sur
les migrations et sur l'asile en Europe
est un débat profondément hypocrite et
qui ne tient absolument pas compte
d'effet ni des réalités des migrations
et qui cherche simplement à plaire à un
certain électorat et donc effectivement
madame Meloni a été élu sur cette
promesse elle ne peut pas évidemment se
dédire aujourd'hui pour des raisons
politiques même si bien sûr l'économie
italienne comme l'économie française la
plupart des écoles européennes auraient
besoin de main d'oeuvre étrangère le
problème c'est que on refuse de
l'organiser on refuse de la mettre en
place et donc on est toujours dans cette
logique de fermeture des frontières et
de fermetures des portes on arrive à ces
situations qui créent à la fois des
drames de la migration il faut rappeler
qu'il y a des des demandeurs d'asile qui
sont très très mal en point sur ce
bateau et aussi des crises politiques
comme la crise diplomatique qu'on
connaît en ce moment entre la France et
l'Italie oui alors on est dans ce
premier cette première partie de débat
plutôt sur les conséquences on va dire
intérieur que ce soit en Italie ou en
France et justement Laetitia c'est
intéressant parce que alors c'est
presque un cliché quand on parle de
d'Emmanuel Macron et de l'immigration
c'est un peu l'angle mort de sa
politique à force de l'entente de la
bouche des politiques bien sûr de
l'opposition et des journalistes Thomas
il faut bien le dire on prend pour faire
acquis que finalement Emmanuel Macron ne
sait pas y faire en matière
d'immigration mais la la question s'il
vous plaît de reformuler la
problématique c'est plutôt de se poser
la question de est-ce que sur ce sujet
inflammable de l'immigration on peut
être ni de droite ni de gauche est-ce
que c'est possible d'avoir une politique
ni de droite ni de gauche sur
l'immigration et la réponse et non et
c'est peut-être une petite explication
en tout cas un début d'explication des
haters moments d'Emmanuel Macron sur le
sujet alors pourquoi vous nous dites que
c'est encore difficile de comprendre
finalement la la cohérence ou le cap
d'Emmanuel Macron en la matière en fait
c'est difficile de comprendre quand par
exemple on regarde des reproches on y
fait alors aujourd'hui il est carrément
laxiste quand on écoute le camp de
droite on n'a pas entendu non plus le
camp de gauche applaudir dès demain pour
cette demi solution de Toulon alors que
hier enfin il y a quelques années en
2018 par exemple alors que Édouard
Philippe défend et mène la loi asile et
immigration l'Obs fait cette une on va
la voir une une choque avec l'image
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est inséré dans
des barbelés et puis un code couleur
aussi qui est assez significatif et
l'année suivante pourtant Emmanuel
Macron poursuit sa politique musclée
alors lui cette fois-ci en allant vers
un magazine qui est on va dire Zemmour
compatible en valeur actuelle il accorde
en 2019 une interview exclusive à ce
magazine sur l'immigration et donc ça
provoque à nouveau intolé général c'est
tout juste si on n'accuse pas d'être
fasciste donc depuis son jeu de mots un
jeu mauvais depuis le début Emmanuel
Macron Tang sur la question et ça s'est
entendu encore ce matin puisque avant la
prise de décision les plusieurs
ministres les lieutenants du
gouvernement étaient un peu sur des il
savait pas sur quels financer en quelque
sorte alors illustration tout de suite
sur France 2 par exemple un Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'Économie dit que le
bateau doit retourner en Italie écouter
pour le moment je rappelle juste la
règle européenne parce que si on
commence à dévier par rapport à cette
règle là il y a plus de solidarité
possible il y a plus de gestion efficace
des flux migratoires donc je souhaite
que la règle européenne soit respectée
que l'Italie accueille dans un de ses
ports de ce bateau de migrants
quasiment au même moment Clément bonne
lui dit que il faut mettre en garde
quand même contre un renvoi de ce même
bateau il faut faire attention écouter
le nous avons accueilli le plus de
migrants débarquer de ces bateaux je le
dis moi c'est notre honneur mais on doit
le faire dans le principe de sauvetage
et d'humanité qui protègent le mieux les
migrants en difficulté et les migrants
qui sont sauvés et en attendant on a
entendu tout à l'heure vos projets
ce qu'en pense l'extrême droite
française parce que si ces solutions
comme on l'a entendu dans l'hémicycle
c'est de renvoyer les bateaux en Afrique
ça n'est tout simplement pas possible
pour des raisons militaires sauf à
condamné à mort ces migrants donc qui
nous disent aussi ce qu'ils entendent de
défendre entre l'intérêt national et
européen ou leurs amis extrêmement en
Italie vous voyez qu'entre Bruno Le
Maire est clairement beau il y a quand
même deux voies dissonantes alors quand
à l'extrême droite on connaît leur
position à Marine Le Pen avec Zemmour
Jordan Bardella ont tous dit qu'il
retourne de là où ils viennent donc ça
c'est très très clair mais on voit quand
même qu'il y a une certaine célébrités à
un mois à peu près de la présentation de
la loi à l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'immigration une fébrilité de
l'exécutif pourquoi parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron a quand même été élu deux fois il
faut le rappeler avec des électeurs et
des voix de gauche contre Marine Le Pen
qui est d'extrême droite et donc
Emmanuel Macron est obligé aussi de
tenir compte de ces électeurs là quand
ils mènent sa politique d'immigration on
verra ce que ça donne dans un mois Lévy
vous êtes un observateur
pointu de la politique française pour
les médias italiens pour lesquels vous
travaillez est-ce que le en même temps
macroniste est adapté à la politique
d'immigration non on a vu toutes les
limites de ce de cette attitude mais on
voit de la même façon les limites de
l'extrême droite souverainiste parce que
jusqu'à il y a encore 24 heures
l'extrême droite de Marine Le Pen était
la principale alliée de Matéo Salvin en
Italie il s'affichait main dans la main
etc et là les intérêts de ces deux
souverainismes on se rend compte que qui
sont complètement contrastants et
l'intérêt d'un souverainisme en France
et exactement
l'inverse de l'intérêt d'un
souverainisme en Italie donc c'est un
court-circuit incroyable qui est en
train de se produire dans les extrêmes
droites européennes et ça montre une
seule chose que en se repliant sur
soi-même nous les Européens on peut
aller nulle part ailleurs et que
aujourd'hui toute forme de patriotisme
doit passer par une dimension européenne
parce qu'aujourd'hui le nationalisme et
le pire ennemi du patriotisme alors
c'est intéressant comme en Italie alors
justement j'apporte un élément à votre
démonstration une réaction du nouveau
président du Rassemblement national il
vient tout juste d'être voilà
massivement choisi à la tête du
rassemblement national c'est Jordan
barnella évidemment voilà ce qu'il nous
disait sur l'otion Viking écoutez notre
position est claire elle est ferme et
avec nous le champ de Viking ne pourrait
pas accoster sur les côtes françaises
parce que tu veux c'est un c'est une
pompe aspirante c'est un cycle sans fin
François jeumaine je reviens vers vous
est-ce que l'alliance des souverainistes
parce qu'elle existe d'une certaine
façon
en Europe est-ce qu'elle se fracasse
finalement sur cette question migratoire
je suis face je suis pas certain parce
que la difficulté évidemment c'est que
la logique souverainise c'est de
renvoyer le problème chez le voisin et
donc c'est très difficile d'avoir une
sorte de vision souverainiste au niveau
européen a fortiori quand certains
gouvernements ne sont pas souverainistes
mais je pense néanmoins qui est un axe
très très fort notamment au moment où on
va le rediscuter du pacte sur l'asile à
l'admiration je pense qu'il y en a qui
est très très fort des souverainistes en
Europe qui va sans doute devenir à terme
majoritaire très clairement je reste sur
le les effets ce que vous évoquiez
Laetitia sur le finalement la politique
française avec ce communiqué publié ce
jeudi après-midi par Bruno retaillod
candidat à la présidente LR vous le
savez président du groupe LR ici au
Sénat il affirme que l'océan Viking
n'est que le cheval de Troie de
l'immigration irrégulière en Europe il
pointe un détournement du droit de
sauvetage en droit de passage et li dans
la même phrase c'est navires affrété par
des ONG au trafic très lucratif
d'escrocs sans scrupules je me tourne
vers vous Gérard François Dumont est-ce
que
ce que veut dire pour moi cette phrase
de Bono est-ce que le chien Viking est
un complice de fait des mafia et des
passeurs alors c'est tout de problème de
l'interprétation du droit maritime
international c'est à dire que
effectivement nous avons un bateau qui
se trouve au milieu de la Méditerranée
normalement ce bateau ne peut entrer
dans l'ésotéritoriales d'un pays que si
ce pays le souhaite et d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle en fait la France
pour le moment n'avait jamais accepté ce
genre de bateau je crois que ce qui est
important de noter c'est c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a quand même une
décision qui fait novation par rapport à
ce qui était la doctrine française dans
les décennies précédentes et donc est-ce
que cette décision complètement nouvelle
va être un coup une fois ou est-ce que
ça va vraiment modifier complètement
l'attitude de la France de façon
structurelle parce que je sais bien que
monsieur darbada a dit c'est
exceptionnel mais enfin les les
décisions exceptionnelles qui qui donne
lieu à des répétitions sont même assez
connu alors c'est vrai si vous voulez
pour les passeurs c'est un marché
extrêmement fructueux moi j'avais étudié
notamment les passages là en 2015-2016
il faut considérer que c'était un marché
de 10 milliards d'euros donc c'est tout
à fait considérable et en même temps
vous il y a toutes les familles qui
paient le passage donc ça veut dire
qu'après il faut évidemment rembourser
les familles des frais qu'elles ont
engagés pour payer ce passage parce que
ces personnes qui arrivent en Europe
même si elles ont un salaire très faible
mais dans un salaire au SMIC elles
envoient en gros 20% de leur salaire au
pays d'origine bon alors 20% c'est peu
20% d'un SMIC mais en pouvoir d'achat
dans le pays d'origine ça représente des
sommes qui sont significatives et qui
permettent effectivement d'améliorer la
situation de la famille donc si vous
voulez c'est pour ça que je dis que
c'est un impro Clio parce qu'il y a
cette dimension économique qu'il ne faut
pas oublier et la dimension juridique
lié à l'interprétation du droit maritime
international mais est-ce que ça veut
dire que il y a pas de réelle volonté
politique de casser ces mafia ou est-ce
que c'est trop compliqué voilà parce
qu'on pourrait considérer que une action
concertée des pays d'origine et des pays
d'accueil pourraient permettre de buter
efficacement contre ces informations
dont je dispose il y a un manque de
volonté politique de casser ces mafia
pourquoi parce que c'est mafia elles
utilisent quand même des moyens de
communication et ces moyens de
communication nous pouvons les écouter
grâce à nos satellites et donc on sait
très bien ce qu'elles font mais le
problème aussi c'est que pour casser ces
mafia faudrait pouvoir intervenir
militairement par exemple sur le
territoire de la Libye ou bien vous avez
certains chefs de ces mafia qui en ce
moment sont dans des belles villas dans
le nord de Chypre donc dans la partie
cypriote qui est en fait
occupée par la Turquie ou là il n'y a
aucun droit international qui s'applique
et ils ne seront jamais expulsés de
chiffreur pour un tribunal européen par
exemple si on intervient à Chypre si on
intervient en Libye pour
si on en intervient assez c'est en fait
l'équivalent d'une attaque
internationale c'est on est dans un
conflit international
automatiquement donc ce qui fait que
c'est vrai par exemple l'Italie dans le
passé a essayé d'intervenir à travers le
gouvernement officiel de la Libye mais
c'était à des moments où ce gouvernement
avait des contreparties significatives
je ne sais pas de même que l'Italie
comme vous le savez avait passé des
accords avec Kadhafi pour que Kadhafi
effectivement ne
décourage disons le déversement d'un
certain nombre de migrés à travers la
Méditerranée donc c'est pour ça que la
question extrêmement complexe parce que
nous avons tous les éléments si vous
voulez tout l'éventail économique
politique juridique mafieux qui se
réunit sur cette affaire alors on va
ouvrir dans un instant le chapitre
vraiment européen le droit européen et
les conséquences de ce de cette crise à
long terme mais je vous ai pas entendu
sur sur Macron et sa politique
migratoire c'est dommage parce qu'elle
Perrineau est-ce que finalement
l'absence de majorité parlementaire du
président aujourd'hui pas forcément le
pousser vers plutôt une politique de
droite ça semblerait logique en effet
parce que si vous voulez dans cette
situation tout même assez rocambolesque
la France connaît depuis les dernières
législatives il y a pas beaucoup de
marge de manœuvre pour le gouvernement
et quand les marges de manœuvre existent
elles sont à droite elles sont pas à
gauche puisque les groupes de la nupesse
sont sur une position qui est le refus
de toute aide à la majorité relative
macronienne donc c'est à droite et
d'autre part quand vous regardez
attentivement ce qui a fait la victoire
toi-même claire du président de la
République aux dernières élections c'est
sa droitisation il a
et son électorat est un électorat il y a
encore des électeurs de gauche en effet
mais c'est un électorat beaucoup plus à
droite qu'en 2017 donc il sait très bien
qu'il faut qu'il parle avant tout certes
à toute la France mais d'abord à celles
et ceux qui l'ont élu et donc la
tentation est la tentation dans le haut
de droite et de gauche de privilégier je
crois le et de droite même s'il cherche
on le voit sur le terrain de l'éducation
à entretenir les ambiguïtés après
Blanquer on a eu pas peine d'y aller
c'est plutôt là le et de gauche qu'il
parle donc on peut toujours avoir avec
Emmanuel Macron des surprises mais
d'autre part sur si vous voulez c'est un
problème sur lequel l'opinion est très
réactive et l'opinion en effet de
manière claire depuis des années
considère qu'il y a trop d'étrangers en
France voilà c'est 60% à peu près en
moyenne de Français qui considèrent mais
quand les questions deviennent plus
précises les Français considèrent par
exemple que sur terrain économique il y
a un besoin de main d'oeuvre étrangère
donc vous voyez ça n'est pas un rejet
tout azimut de toute forme de migration
et donc l'idée d'une migration choisie
d'une migration par Quota à certainement
en termes d'opinion
un accueil plutôt plutôt favorable mais
dès que réapparaissent
j'allais dire ce qui incendie l'opinion
c'est-à-dire la question de l'islamisme
la question du terrorisme etc alors là
tout le mouvement s'inverse et les
majorités deviennent des minorités
d'accueil
comme promis j'ouvre maintenant le
chapitre sur les conséquences de cette
crise en Europe et peut-être d'abord
Paolo sur les rapports entre la France
et l'Italie c'est de la fin du nidylle
on peut dire ça d'une certaine façon
c'est la fin
d'une lune de miel extraordinaire ou
j'ose dire depuis la pandémie l'Italie
et la France était devenu presque une
seule République parce que on s'est
retrouvés en symbiose totale sur des
référents formes majeures en Europe il y
a eu vraiment l'impensable qui s'est
produit ces dernières années ça peut
paraître un peu technocratique mais en
fait c'est extraordinaire le plan de
relance qui a été européen qui a été
approuvé en juillet 2020 à introduit
pour la première fois en Europe une
forme de mutualisation de la dette ça
veut dire quoi c'est une vraie
fraternité européenne qui s'est mise en
place et cela a été possible surtout
grâce au travail de la France avec
l'Italie à côté plein d'autres pays de
bonne volonté qui pour la première fois
c'était jamais arrivé en 70 ans
d'histoire d'intégration européenne on a
fait basculer la position de l'Allemagne
qui pour la première fois à accepter ce
principe le grand défi de Rome et Paris
jusqu'à il y a encore quelques mois a
été celui de transformer ce principe de
mutualisation qui était bien
conjoncturel c'est-à-dire lié uniquement
à la crise sanitaire structurelle c'est
à dire pour répondre pas toutes les
crises qui vont certainement nous
secouer aujourd'hui et dans les
prochaines années et aujourd'hui
malheureusement ce chantier est remis en
question après la victoire de Joe jamelo
ni parce que je suis pas sûr que la
France puisse aller dans la main avec
l'Italie comme elle a fait jusqu'ici il
y a plein d'autres chantiers cruciaux en
Europe donc le premier pays qui en
aurait bénéficié aurait été l'Italie je
pense à la réforme du parc de stabilité
à notre chantier qui est Matt qui voyait
Emmanuel Macron et Mario Dragos total le
plafonnement au prix de l'énergie et du
gaz au niveau européen et donc
aujourd'hui cette lune de miel
malheureusement elle s'est brisée sur
les rochers de la politique politicienne
italienne et je suis pas sûr que
l'Italie va être gagné beaucoup de cette
main mais est-ce que pour autant vous
demander réponse assez rapide l'Italie
est plus isolé en Europe aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'était autant de Mario
Draghi
l'Italie en train de s'isoler énormément
dans un moment où elle aurait un besoin
criant de solidarité européenne il faut
bien distinguer deux choses d'un côté il
y a la crise de l'Océanie King ou
Rome a violé tous les principes de
l'État de droit parce que le devoir
d'accueillir les naufragés est un devoir
constitutionnel avant tout donc national
au niveau européen et au niveau des
Nations Unies le droit de la mer et donc
l'Italie c'est isolé et aujourd'hui
c'est et je suis assez convaincu que
cette crise va avoir des répercussions
dans la langue durée
Darmanin a déjà annoncé par exemple que
ce mécaille sur le mécanisme
relocalisation il prévoyait distribuer
3500 réfugiés qui sont actuellement en
Italie en France et dans d'autres pays
voilà on va l'entendre sa déclaration de
Darmanin mais d'abord François Jemen
vous vous évoquez finalement cette
question tout à l'heure quand je vous
demandais est-ce que la crise migratoire
peut fracturer les les souverainistes en
Europe elle est pas seule Georgia Meloni
quand même en Europe
puisque globalement aujourd'hui la la
fracture qui est un peu jadis une
fracture entre l'est et l'ouest de
l'Europe où on peut les pays d'Europe
centrale orientale était considérés
comme les vilains petits canards qui qui
refusaient d'accueillir des réfugiés des
demandeurs d'asile aujourd'hui cette
fracture c'est complètement déplacée il
y a beaucoup d'autres pays qui sont sur
la même ligne que Georgia Meloni il y a
évidemment toujours des pays comme la
Hongrie mais on peut citer des pays
comme comme le Danemark par exemple
comme l'Autriche dans une certaine
mesure comme la Suède désormais ce sont
des pays qui sont globalement sur la
même ligne que Georges jameloni en
matière d'asile et d'immigration
c'est-à-dire globalement des pays qui
voudraient en continent sans asile un
continent sans immigrer je pense que
l'accueil des réfugiés Ukrainiens a pu
faire bouger pas mal de lignes en Europe
centrale orientale c'est-à-dire que des
pays qui jusqu'ici ne voulaient entendre
parler d'un mécanisme de solidarité
européenne était d'un coup confronté à
l'accueil d'un nombre très important de
réfugiés et comprenez qu'il pouvait être
dans leur intérêt au fond de bénéficier
aussi d'un tel mécanisme mais on le voit
bien avec à nouveau ces ces personnes
qui sont secourues par des bateaux de NG
qui doivent rester pendant des jours et
des jours en mer on voit bien que
l'Europe n'a absolument rien appris de
la crise des réfugiés syriens de 2015
2016 on voit bien qu'on en est toujours
au même point et que dès qu'on va
rouvrir le dossier migratoire on va
provoquer une crise diplomatique entre
pays de l'Union européenne l'Europe ne
pourra pas vraiment avancer à mon sens
tant qu'elles ne se sera pas mis
d'accord sur une vraie politique en
matière d'asile et des migration alors
justement on va détailler ces règles
européennes sur l'accueil des migrants
et je propose à terme traduit de nous
rejoindre tout de suite bonsoir Tam
avant de vous donner la parole on écoute
tout de suite justement vous y faisiez
référence Paolo la déclaration du
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
qui annonce la suspension des
engagements français vis-à-vis de
l'Italie ces mécanismes sont pleinement
en fonctionnement depuis plusieurs
semaines l'Italie en est d'ailleurs le
premier des bénéficiaires
3500 realisations de réfugiés étaient
prévus d'ici l'été 2023 il est évident
qu'à effet immédiat la France suspend
l'ensemble des relocalisations donc de
ces 3500 réfugiés au bénéfice de
l'Italie et appelle tous les autres
participants notamment l'Allemagne au
mécanisme européen de faire de même Tam
quels sont les règles européennes en
matière d'accueil des migrants alors que
c'est pas simple mais il y a quand même
une première chose un principe
intangible au niveau international le
sauvetage d'une personne en détresse en
mer il est obligatoire et il est gratuit
ça c'est très clair ça date de 1974
c'est le droit maritime mais après ça se
corse car le droit maritime
international il ne définit pas de
manière claire quel pays doit organiser
le débarquement sur son sol et chaque
État membre normalement au sein l'Union
européenne doit aussi être souverain
dans l'accès à ses ports est-ce que ça
veut dire que chacun chaque pays fait ce
qu'il veut alors quand même pas car il y
a une convention qui date de 1979 la
convention Sark a subdivisé le monde en
13 régions avec chaque région qui est
associée au port le plus proche donc
lorsque le gouvernement dit que l'Italie
violent le droit européen on l'a entendu
notamment de Bruno Le Maire ou de Gérald
Darmanin il se réfère à cet accord on
voit sur cette carte par exemple votre
projetée que les zones sars de Libye
Malte et Italie se touchent un malt et
l'Italie sont vraiment dans la
continuité avec la zone libyenne on l'a
dit tout à l'heure que c'est
actuellement une plateforme essentielle
de passage des migrants doux et bien le
fait qu'il y ait beaucoup de crispations
à ce niveau là les uns et les autres se
renvoient la balle dans une zone où les
frontières sont encore plus floues que
sur terre alors il faut également
différencier le fait
d'accepter l'accostage d'un bateau et le
fait d'accueillir les migrants sur son
sol oui ce sont à la fois de sujets liés
et de sujets distincts regarder par
exemple septembre 2019 c'est l'accord de
La Valette la France l'Italie
l'Allemagne Malte mettent en place un
système de répartition des migrants
secourus en mer l'objectif c'est
d'alléger la charge des États en
première ligne notamment Malte et
l'Italie et l'exemple et bien de
l'application de cet accord c'est fin
octobre 2019 lotion Viking déjà ce cours
104 migrants ils sont répartis
conformément à cet accord par exemple 70
d'entre eux sont accueillis en France et
en Allemagne les autres sont accueillis
en Italie alors que le navire du coup
est autorisé à accoster au port de
pozzalo à la pointe sud de la Sicile et
l'objectif de cet accord c'est bien
d'éviter la réédition de ces épisodes
des mois qui ont précédé lorsque Mateo
Salvini donc ministre de l'Intérieur
italien à l'époque avait fermé les ports
italiens au navire d'ONG on se rappelle
du souvenir traumatisant de l'Aquarius
en 2018 et notez d'ailleurs que Matteo
Salvini a paru l'année dernière à
Palerme Sicile pour avoir bloqué en mer
un bateau avec 147 migrants à bord
c'était en août 2019 un procès sur
lequel Matteo Salvini a cherché à
capitaliser politiquement il a utilisé
pour s'adresser à son électorat regardez
ce tweet où il dit le procès vous lui
par la gauche et les fans de
l'immigration illégale commence combien
cela va-t-il coûter au citoyens italiens
alors aujourd'hui on en est où il y a
aujourd'hui et bien l'Union européenne
ne parvient pas à se mettre d'accord
pour accueillir les migrants on l'a
expliqué l'Europe de l'Est l'Europe
centrale mais pas seulement il y a aussi
d'autres pays qui freinent des quatre
fers mais tout de même en juin 2022 il y
a eu un pack qui a été signé pas partout
les États membres mais quelques-uns qui
prévoit que les États soient accueille
des demandeurs d'asile soit verse une
compensation financière un mécanisme de
solidarité qui a été ardemment défendue
par la France mais on a encore loin d'un
véritable pacte qui concerne l'ensemble
des pays européens merci beaucoup Thom
traduit pour toutes ces explications
Gérard François Dumont répartir les
migrants par pays est-ce que c'est
forcément une c'est le type même de la
fausse bonne idée pourquoi pour une
raison bien simple c'est que les
migrants ne sont pas des meubles les
migrants sont des êtres humains qui ont
aussi des projets qui peuvent choisir
les pays qui veulent aller et certains
vont vouloir choisir les Pays-Bas parce
qu'il a un cousin ou un voisin qui est
déjà installé au Pays-Bas il sait qu'il
va l'aider à trouver un logement à
trouver un emploi à connaître les
méthodes de travail au Pays-Bas et puis
un autre envie d'aller en Angleterre ou
d'aller en Allemagne
cette répartition en fonction des
besoins des supposerait effectivement
qu'il y a une instance qui leur demande
un petit peu leur intention le véritable
problème on voit bien on n'arrive pas à
voir de politique migratoires commune il
y a de multiples raisons mais parmi les
raisons il faut quand même tenir compte
de la question de l'emploi la question
de l'emploi est très différente selon
les pays européens vous rappelez que le
tort ce qu'on peut reprocher à Madame
Merkel en 2015 c'est surtout qu'elle n'a
pas prévenu les autres pays européens de
la décision elle allait prendre et donc
elle a donné l'impression de pas se
désintéresser de l'Union européenne
d'accueillir un million de de
suspendre la mise en œuvre de ce qu'on
appelle les accords de Dublin on sait la
raison pour laquelle bon je comprends
très bien ce que dit Gérard Dahmane
géralda Mardin mais c'est 3500 ça change
pas grand chose à la réalité parce que
la réalité c'est quand même que la
majorité des migrants qui arrivent par
l'Italie vont déposer des demandes
d'asile dans d'autres pays de l'Italie
c'est déjà le cas et donc ça ça ne va
pas c'est pas ça qui va effrayer le
gouvernement italien à mon avis donc
nous avons cette cette difficulté de
l'Allemagne qui est un pays dans la
population active diminue donc il y a un
aide besoin de main d'oeuvre et toutes
choses égales par ailleurs en fait la
France a moins besoin de main d'oeuvre
son problème c'est que son temps
d'emploi est faible et surtout qu'elle a
un taux de chômage chez les immigrés qui
est élevé et surtout sur un certain
nombre d'immigrés qui viennent de
Turquie ou qui viennent d'Algérie avec
d'autres chômage qui sont parfois le
trip de la moyenne française donc le
problème c'est plutôt de mettre au
travail de mettre en emploi des
personnes qui ne le sont pas d'activités
qui sont sinistrés alors avec des c'est
ça le le paradoxe effectivement de la de
la France et d'un autre côté vous avez
toujours le souci effectivement des des
populations accueillantes qui se disent
mais si on embauche trop d'immigrés à
des salaires de misère finalement ils
viennent nous concurrencer il faut se
rappeler quand même que l'une des
raisons du vote du brexit ce sont ces
anglais de de basse catégories
socio-professionnelles qui considérait
que les Polonais les concurrencés sur le
marché du travail en acceptant des
salaires très bas François Germaine avec
ce changement climatique et vous êtes
l'un des spécialistes de cette question
le le flux de réfugiés une double j'ai
une question à double entrée est-ce que
le flux de réfugiés va forcément
augmenter
face à cette situation est-ce que
l'Europe fait un peu l'autruche
aujourd'hui
je dirais pas que l'Europe fait
l'autruche aujourd'hui il faut savoir
que depuis 2016 a été créé une
organisation internationale pour essayer
de faire avancer de protéger les droits
des personnes déplacées par le
changement climatique qui s'appelle la
plateforme sur les déplacements liés au
catastrophe l'Union européenne prendra
la présidence de ces organisations qui
établies à Genève le 1er janvier
prochain et c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression que personne en France dans
le débat public n'est au courant de
l'organisation de pardon d'être au
courant de de l'existence de cette
organisation
pour l'instant l'essentiel des personnes
déplacées par les effets du changement
climatique migrent à l'intérieur de leur
pays mais c'est un très grand nombre de
personnes chaque année il y a deux à
trois fois plus de personnes déplacées
par des catastrophes climatiques que de
personnes déplacées par des guerres et
par des violences par exemple en 2021
l'an dernier il y a eu à peu près 24
millions de personnes déplacées par des
ouragans des inondations des sécheresses
ou des incendies et donc on est face à
un des principaux facteurs de migration
et de déplacements aujourd'hui pour
autant il faut bien se rendre compte que
si ces migrations aujourd'hui sont
essentiellement des migrations internes
il y a également de nombreuses
migrations internationales qui sont
aussi motivés par des facteurs
climatiques environnementaux mais qui ne
sont pas désignés comme tel une partie
des migrants dit économiques qui
arrivent en provenance de l'Europe de
l'Ouest par exemple sont aussi des
migrants écologiques ou climatiques
simplement parce qu'en Afrique de
l'Ouest un ménage sur deux dépend de
l'agriculture de subsistance comme
première source de revenus l'agriculture
de subsistance est un type d'agriculture
qui est très vulnérable à toute
variation de la température la plus
vieux métrique et dès lors dès qu'ils
fabuleux show qui pleut un peu moins et
bien c'est la moitié des ménages en
Afrique subsaharienne qui perd sa source
première de revenus et une des
stratégies des ménages c'est évidemment
d'envoyer un ou plusieurs de leur fils à
la ville et puis parfois de proche en
proche c'est comme ça qu'ils vont
arriver sur sur les côtes européennes
donc aujourd'hui on a des facteur
l'intégrations qui sont très mêlées et
très liées les uns aux autres et si nous
ne respectons pas les accords de Paris
et bien il est probable que certaines
zones du monde vont devenir
littéralement inhabitable ce qui va
poser la question d'un d'une
redistribution géographique de la
population et c'est évidemment c'est un
débat auquel nous ne sommes pas encore
prêts du tout en témoignent encore se
sordide marchandage et cette négociation
entre la France et l'Italie sur le chef
viking merci beaucoup merci François
Germaine je rappelle le titre de votre
livre l'écologie n'est pas un consensus
qui est publié aux éditions Fayard merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
bientôt dans le sens public